consider the following imagine two
rooms inside each room is a switch
outside each room is a lamp in one room
there is a man who flips his switch
according to a coin flip if he lands
heads the switch is on if he lands tails
the switch is off in the other room a
woman switches her light based on a
blind guess she tries to simulate
Randomness without a coin then we start
a clock and they make their switches in
unison
now the interesting question can you
determine which light bulb is being
switched by a coin flip the answer is to
count sequences of numbers a true random
sequence will be equally likely to
contain every sequence of any length if
we flip a coin 10 times it is equally
likely to come up all heads all Tails or
any other sequence you can think
of